i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
this is a major story we're starting
with today republicans have been caught
in a series of presentations audio
recordings and power points openly
planning to win elections not by
actually winning the hearts and minds of
voters and getting people to the polls
and winning elections in a real way
they've been caught planning to win by a
strategic and concerted effort
to just contest ballots to claim fraud
and this plan in and of itself is a form
of voter fraud
we are going to listen to the recordings
we are going to look at what we have
learned
and one of the things that i said back
in 2020
when six months before the november 2020
election donald trump and others started
saying oh it's going to be fraud he
would say fraud he would say the paper
ballots
the mail-in ballots absent it's all
fraudulent they're going to try to take
it it's going to be insecure
and what i said at the time was you know
at some point in the future
they are actually going to attempt
massive voter fraud and we're going to
call them out and then they're going to
say oh come on you're the guys who said
there was no fraud when we were pointing
to the fraud in 2020 and that is
happening right now because remember
with republicans with the modern right
wing in the united states
every time they make an allegation
we should consider and explore whether
it's actually a confession of something
they're planning to do oh hillary can't
be trusted with with sensitive
information trump's eating documents
flushing documents and stealing
documents to mar-a-lago when they say
the left is doing something the first
question we should ask is are they
actually the ones doing this is that how
they think it's something someone might
do because they are the ones doing it so
they are conspiring to win elections win
by contesting ballots of democrats not
by actually convincing people to vote
for them explosive political report
it's going to be an army tapes reveal
republican plan to contest elections
placing operatives as poll workers and
building a hotline to friendly attorneys
are among the strategies to be deployed
in michigan and other swing states this
is incredibly important stuff to know
about now because if we're not ready to
fight this they could get away with it
think about we you know thank goodness
they didn't get away with it in 2020.
but you could argue that it was a trial
run and that they're going to try again
and there's every indication they're
going to
heidi prisbilla for politico quote video
recordings of republican party
operatives meeting with grassroots
grassroots activists provide an inside
look at a multi-pronged strategy to
target and potentially overturn votes in
democratic precincts they're targeting
the democratic precincts install trained
recruits as regular poll workers and put
them in direct contact with party
attorneys the plan is outlined by a
republican national committee staffer in
michigan includes utilizing rules
designed to provide political balance
among poll workers to install
party-trained volunteers prepared to
challenge voters as democratic majority
polling places
at democratic majority polling places
developing a website to connect workers
to local lawyers and establishing a
network of party-friendly das who could
intervene to block vote counts at
certain precincts so here's the strategy
okay
most polling places
generally speaking have a system for
uh poll workers
and poll watchers
most of those systems are designed that
there be partisan balance you can't have
all democrats watching a poll a polling
place or all republicans
the idea would be you have a partisan
balance
but these are all just kind of
good faith people who are there
genuinely to make sure that everything
is being done in the correct way the
republican plan is to take advantage of
the rules which say you have to have
some democrats and some republicans
there has to be balance
and to train the republican poll workers
to understand how to disproportionately
challenge democratic votes by virtue of
being in overwhelmingly democratic
precincts
uh in order to have balance on paper
listen we've still got democratic poll
workers and republican poll workers it's
all fine
but the republican workers that are poll
workers that are there
are there not to make sure everything is
on the up and up
but they are there because these are
left-leaning precincts where they are
going to try to help republicans by
challenging votes that will
statistically be more likely to be
democratic rather than republican votes
being a poll worker you just have so
many more rights and things you can do
to stop something than as a poll
challenger
so again the idea here is
don't have them there
as the obviously partisan poll
challengers have them there just as
regular poll workers who are going to
say they're seeing funny business we
have audio recordings let's take a
listen to one understand that we're
upset with the 2020 results but we
cannot just look at the 2020 results or
else the exact same thing will happen in
2022. we need volunteers on the ground
on election day ahead of election day
working
so that that fraud does not happen again
if we only look at 2020 it just will
happen i work the polls the last
election
and not only were we extremely poorly
trained i mean badly trained
but when we caught them cheating and i
caught them cheating
they they had a pre-planned thing that
they did they would swarm you they
blocked you from seeing things they
accused you of doing things that you
weren't doing and then they would go
like this and you have the police coming
out so that that's why we're here now
today 13 months ahead of exactly
as opposed as opposed to one month ahead
of it so if i could ask everyone just to
listen to matt and by the way the reason
that they're saying 13 months is the the
recordings from october these recordings
were just recently published so they're
talking about october 2021 13 months
before this coming november election
this plan is for the november elections
presentation
and then we can ask questions afterwards
that would be greatly appreciated
but seriously though that's why we're on
the ground like rob said it's so early
to address exactly that right the
democrats and i'm just going to go off
scripts
right away so um we are trying to
recruit truly it's going to be an army
right we are going to try to recruit
lawyers we're going to have more lawyers
than i've ever been recruited because
let's be honest that's where it's going
to be fought right we're going to have
lawyers that work early to build
relationships with different judges so
that when that happens we're going to
have lawyers that have relationships
with the police chiefs in the different
areas the police chief the police so
you're going to have
install republican
uh bad faith poll workers to contest
ballots
have them be in touch with lawyers and
the lawyers know the police chief so
maybe they can even involve police in
helping to skew the elections in their
favor
so when that happens those pre-existing
relationships are already established so
that they can't lie so that they i i've
talked with so many people that work at
the tcf center and that i've heard that
happens it happened right no one is just
like it happened and it's wrong that it
happened it's 100 wrong that it happened
and we're going to address it we're
going to address it by having the
lawyers on the ground we're going to
address it by trying to have it so the
plan is as follows in most places in
many places we'll talk about detroit
michigan because this is one one place
that this is becoming a very big deal
um the poll workers have to be selected
from names submitted by each of the
parties
great
so
we know that detroit is a particularly
blue part of michigan so if you want to
skew a state election
you don't know whether a particular
voter is a republican or a democrat so
you say okay well listen if michigan is
in general is a i don't know what the
numbers are imagine it's a 52 to 48
state or a 55-45 democratic-leaning
state but you know detroit is like 75
democratic great so what you do is you
train a bunch of people to be poll
workers uh who know the process for
contesting ballots
say that i don't believe that this is a
valid voter you force them to have to
submit a contested ballot which then has
to be adjudicated and on and on and on
you train them up
and then
the list that the republican party
submits in detroit right they don't have
to do this everywhere you say we're
going to target detroit because that's
where we can make a difference it's so
many democrats we'll try to fight the
validity of democratic ballots for no
particular reason other than their
democrats
the list that you submit in detroit to
the county to the election uh uh clerk
or
the the detroit official that chooses
the poll workers is all these people who
have been trained in bad faith not to
prevent fraud but to try to get votes in
detroit thrown out which are
overwhelmingly likely to be democratic
votes and so then
that's how you skew the results you let
the vote happen in other parts of
michigan that are more 50 50 or even the
rural parts of michigan which you're
republican
but in detroit you send this army of
poll workers who are actually bad faith
sort of like undercover political
operatives
to try to get democratic votes
discounted and they've got lawyers ready
they claim they're going to have police
chiefs ready now what is happening here
is that to win
they increasingly must cheat at least
apparently well why would that be
it's because on the issues the country
is moving more and more to the left
they're losing on the issues okay and by
the way i encourage you to listen to
these recordings in full there's an
eight-minute recording from an october
5th
election integrity training
and then there's another 14-minute
recording of a zoom meeting and you will
very quickly
understand the strategy uh which we have
more or less explained here
if democrats wait until after it happens
it's going to be too late
and it's really important to understand
how
monumental the outcome of these midterms
will be because in 2020 they had a bunch
of different strategies they tried uh it
was the national the compense overturned
it alternate slates of electors
objections on january 6 all these
different things more than 60 court
cases which failed trying to prevent
mail-in and absentee ballots they had
all these different things it didn't
work but it could have and now they're
going to refine the strategy and 2022 is
going to be a test of how much closer
can we get to just controlling the
election results by using these
techniques
so that in 2024 we might be able to just
get a president that didn't really win
installed in the white house
and there's a second layer to that
it's not just testing the techniques
it's also
can we use the techniques in 2022 we
being them
can we use the techniques in 2022
to get enough control over state
positions including secretaries of state
and governors etc
so that those individuals will be in
power in november of 2024
to maybe do what trump wanted
um brad raffensberger and brian kemp to
do
in georgia for example remember that i
need 11 000 votes give me a break
it didn't happen in georgia but what
about doug mastriano in pennsylvania
doug mastriano the now winner of the
republican gubernatorial primary in
pennsylvania
he's a big lie supporter and he's worse
than that by the way if you look at his
background
he might be willing
to do the things trump wanted them to do
in georgia in 2024 if he's the governor
so what if they use these techniques to
get masteriano in in 2022
so that he will be in power to do this
stuff in 2024. we cannot understate the
importance of these midterms so should
everyone vote of course that's number
one
but the democratic party
had better be ready to fight this now do
they have to fight fire with fire
meaning just set up democratic poll
workers to try to do this exact same
thing in republican areas well number
one i think that that's going low so i
don't think that's the way to do it and
number two by its nature
because republicans are more uh
predominant in rural areas with lower
populations
democrats are at a structural
disadvantage republicans can focus their
bad faith poll workers in the densely
populated areas
for democrats to fight that they would
need way more poll workers because you
would need them in way more precincts
because they're going to be more rural
precincts so
it's both a bad idea
and a difficult idea logistically
because of that so democrats need to
come up with something and i don't know
what the answer is i just learned about
this story yesterday i'm still thinking
about it but it is looking very very
rough let me know what you think find me
on twitter at d pacman and tuesday june
14th at 6 00 p.m will be the next david
pakman show town hall it'll stream live
on the pacman live youtube channel i'll
have more information on that uh between
now and then
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens
you get an immediate alert on your phone
and then aura can help me fix it as well
aura is letting my audience try it free
for two weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below
we have been on this story from the
beginning and it has now been confirmed
exclusively by newsweek based on a
classified report that they've obtained
that yes russian president vladimir
putin
has received treatment for cancer and
has suffered an assassination attempt
which we will talk about as well now if
you've been watching our show listening
to the podcast this general story would
not be new to you there are many media
outlets that have not even talked about
this possibility but our audience many
of you will remember this it seemed that
something was wrong back on april 25th
when we reported in a segment called
visibly bloated putin grips table for
support in new video
that something seemed very wrong and
that was after earlier speculation from
some doctors in our audience that
something seemed just not quite right
with vladimir putin
now then in may we reported on the
belief that putin had cancer it was more
specifically being discussed at that
point in time
and three days after we did that video
ukraine's head of intelligence major
general kirilo boudinov told uk sky news
that putin was in quote a very bad
psychological and physical condition and
he is very sick but okay i mean that's
ukraine's head of intelligence it may be
accurate but ukraine may also have
reasons to push that narrative um and
the context here is very important
because the question we've been asking
is
why is putin acting so seemingly
belligerently this invasion of ukraine
seems like a bad idea it's now been
going on even longer and it's not clear
that it's one that necessarily russia is
going to be able to quote win at least
not decisively at least not without
suffering massive losses on which we've
already reported so one of the theory
and i didn't i actually i shouldn't say
theory even though i mean theory
colloquially
one of the hypotheses or speculations
was
if putin were ill
either as a result of
he feels like he has nothing to lose or
as a side effect of medication all
speculative
maybe he's not thinking clearly and he's
acting belligerently and he wants to go
out in some kind of blazing glory trying
to return
russia to the ussr era you know again it
was all speculative but the question was
could something medical maybe relate to
why he's behaving in this way
and the answer now appears to be well at
least maybe because it now has uh
apparently been confirmed that putin was
treated for cancer and we're going to
talk about what specifically is being
reported a classified us report
obtained by newsweek
says that vladimir putin has re-emerged
after undergoing treatment for cancer in
april
for what they are describing as quite
advanced cancer according to three u.s
intelligence leaders from this
classified report the report also
confirms that there was an assassination
attempt on putin's life in march now
we've seen these videos of when putin
meets with people he's he sits very far
from them these cartoonishly long tables
and that applies to
other uh people that work for him within
russia but also even sometimes when he
meets with foreign leaders and there
were two speculations there one
speculation is he's worried about an
assassination attempt including maybe
that the people even that work for him
might turn on him and try to kill him
now it is learned that he did there was
an assassination attempt in march
secondly the speculation was well maybe
he's just like really afraid of covid
maybe because he's immunocompromised as
a result of possible treatment that he's
receiving many cancer treatments and
other treatments can suppress your
immune system and that would be another
potential explanation this report
doesn't clarify whether it's one the
other or both because both things appear
to have to appear to be true
three intelligence officials from the
office of the dni
a retired air force senior officer and
an official from the defense
intelligence agency say it's difficult
to know exactly what's going on
but that number one the main points of
putin is afraid of assassination
attempts and putin did undergo treatment
for cancer those two points are being
reported as being true according to this
classified report the three intelligence
officials also say that this makes the
prospect of nuclear war less likely
which has been a concern for a while
they don't elaborate as to why and i'm
not actually sure why they believe
this report about putin's uh cancer
treatment
makes nuclear war less likely maybe
we'll get more information about that
um also interesting the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov a major
propagandist
he was asked about this notion of putin
being sick in an interview last weekend
on french television and he straight up
denied it he said quote i don't think
that a sane person can suspect any signs
of an illness or ailment in this man
and if sergey lavrov is so vehemently
denying something
it genuinely might point to it being
true because that the guy is just a
constant and total liar so the bottom
line here according to the defense
intelligence agency official is putin is
definitely sick but whether he is close
to death is mere speculation we just
have no idea
natural question if someone has
undergone cancer treatment well what
type of cancer unclear the speculation
over the last two months has been
prostate cancer
thyroid cancer but it is merely
speculation at this point there have
also been speculations about uh
parkinson's or something parkinsonian
you could have cancer and parkinson's
there are
now with the cancer piece more in focus
there's also speculation that
the parkinsonian appearance may have
been a result of maybe medication or
treatment but again there are lots of
speculative elements the one that seems
to now be out of the realm of
speculation and into the line of fact
based on the classified report is yes
cancer of some kind and treatment in
april um
will we ever know the full truth maybe i
don't know
but a very very interesting report and
it seems that what was believed early on
indeed appears to be at least to some
degree now confirmed let's talk about
today's mass shooting i guess it's
actually yesterday's
but what a country
that when we say
the mass shooting i i have to speculate
not the one from last tuesday
and not the one from the previous
weekend
i'm talking about the one from yesterday
another
horrifying event
four people have been killed in a mass
shooting at a tulsa oklahoma
it's sometimes being discussed this
described as a hospital maybe more
accurately a medical building
the gunman is also dead cbs news has
a report that contains much of the
information we now know
four people were killed in a shooting
last night wednesday evening in a
medical building on a hospital campus in
tulsa oklahoma the gunman is also dead
apparently from a self-inflicted gunshot
wound
tulsa police department captain richard
muellenberg told cnn multiple people
were wounded he said it was fewer than
ten no one had wounds considered
life-threatening so four dead
the shooter dead
an additional up to 10 people wounded
with non-life-threatening injuries he
told the associated press that the
medical complex was a quote catastrophic
scene
the identities of the victims and the
gunmen haven't been released as of this
moment
by the time this story publishes
maybe some of that will have been
released the motive wasn't immediately
known the shooting occurred a little
before five on the campus of saint
francis hospital
officers were there within three minutes
made contact with the gunman within
another five minutes
the police chief says i was very happy
with what we know so far
regarding the response of our officers
certainly
an allusion
to the response at the texas shooting
for sure
officers encountered encountered the
suspect on the second floor of the
hospital's natalie building
the gunman is a black male believed to
be between 35 and 40 armed with a long
gun and a handgun both weapons appeared
to have been fired the officers that did
arrive were hearing shots in the
building and that's what directed them
to the second floor so listen this is
this is another one of these things
where
the the details are catastrophic
the death toll is tragic
um it's it's just it's yet another
shooting
but as always i find it important to
remind you that there have now been 20
mass shootings since last week's
shooting in texas this is sort of like
the next mass shooting that made the
news in a national way
but if you look at
gunviolencearchive.org and you go back
to the day of the texas shooting where
of course 22 were killed and 17 injured
there was a shooting in philly in
stanwood michigan in anniston alabama
memphis tennessee colorado springs one
in florida one in california another one
in tennessee chicago henderson nevada on
and on and on
there have been 20 of these there was a
shooting just two days ago in charleston
south carolina where thankfully no one
was killed but 10 individuals were
injured waco texas had a shooting with
four people injured on uh tuesday and
then we get to this shooting yesterday
in tulsa oklahoma with five killed that
includes the shooter the number injured
has not yet been updated on gun violence
archive.org so it is not
you know it would be bad enough if we
had the buffalo shooting and the texas
shooting and the tulsa shooting
but in between that we've had dozens
more shootings and it just doesn't stop
now after the break
i'm going to be speaking
with democratic congressman jamie raskin
many of you have said david you should
really talk to jamie raskin he's a true
progressive and he he really cares and
if anybody's going to get things done in
this congress it's going to be jamie
raskin well i'm going to speak to him
after the break
and one of the questions i have for him
because we've been hearing anecdotally
this time it's different
this time it's going to be a different
thing it's not going to be
the same again
i'm going to ask jamie raskin is there
actually any willingness from
republicans to do something about gun
safety regulations this time or is it
going to be that same vicious cycle of
thoughts and prayers and no we can't
touch guns that we've seen so many times
before that's after the break make sure
to find us on instagram at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
joinpackman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today democratic congressman jamie
raskin who represents maryland's 8th
congressional district was the lead
house manager in the second impeachment
trial of former president donald trump
uh congressman it's so great to have you
on
i'm delighted to be with you david thank
you for having me so okay to start with
we're going to have starting with in
prime time on june 9th
uh these public hearings related to the
january 6 committee and there are sort
of two opposing forces here there's one
side yourself included who have been
saying what's going to be revealed
during those hearings is going to be
mind-blowing that's my term not
necessarily a term that you have used
the other side is this feeling that
nothing's really going to happen
nobody's ultimately going to be held
accountable for what happened
what can you say to those in my audience
who are in that ladder group who are
concerned about lack of accountability
well
this is all part of the process of
making
the events of january 6 visible
comprehensible to people and making them
the basis of real accountability now
some of that accountability is legal
accountability uh and that's really
within the realm of the department of
justice
uh which has brought more than 800
prosecutions and the most sweeping
investigation in the history of the doj
obviously we're all on the edge of our
seats to see if they're going to work
their way all the way up to the top or
whether uh trump as a
kind of mob boss is able to insulate
himself with several uh
layers of buffer between him and the
criminal actions and the legal
consequences of those actions but i do
think that the investigation is
proceeding a pace and they're working
their way up the way that a lot of
organized crime investigations
work their way up uh the latter but then
there's there's public and political
accountability and that's really what
the january six select committee is all
about i mean under house resolution 503
our job is to report to congress and to
the american people about what happened
on january 6 and what were the causes
behind it and then to make
recommendations about how to fortify our
institutions going forward
do you expect some of your colleagues in
the house may have legal liability
well um
you know
first of all that again that's not
really our role in other words we
understand we are turning and we're
turning over evidence of people
who
are uh
of congress because
they refuse to participate for example
um
dan scavino and peter navarro
um
you know they never
gave a single document to the committee
they never spent one minute testifying
they just blew us off
um mark meadows was kind of one foot in
and one foot out doing the hokey pokey
gave us some stuff and then trump got
mad withdrew um
you know steve bannon's blown us off
we've turned all of that information
over to the department of justice we've
voted told them in contempt and now it's
up to the executive branch and the doj
to enforce that
in terms of evidence of other crimes
we're
in the process of laying them out there
um
and you know in the john eastman
litigation when
uh judge carter uh was dealing with
eastman's
claim that he was somehow covered by
attorney-client privilege
the judge asked the question well was
there an attorney client of privilege
was it waived and um
does it even apply if it existed because
of
the crime fraud exception and we've said
there was no attorney-client privilege
if there was it was waived and
you know
in any event
it doesn't apply because all of these
crimes were committed and we set them
forth and judge carter basically adopted
what we had to say so we've not been shy
about setting forth statutory uh
offenses
um
but look
as much as
we all would like to see
donald trump and
uh others in his uh
inner echelon
uh held legally accountable far more
important is whether or not
we can solidify our democratic
institutions and keep
uh the engines of democracy turning i
mean that's just so much more important
than you know how donald trump
spends the remaining years of his life
whether it's behind bars or somewhere
else i care a lot more about whether or
not we are going to be able to bequeath
the democracy a working functional
democracy to our children and our
grandchildren because the autocrats the
dictators the despots are on the march
all over the world and
from
moscow to mar-a-lago they're working to
undermine democratic process
um
and to drain
uh life from our institutions and we've
got to make sure we've got something to
give our kids yeah to that end i mean it
seems very clear that at least to some
degree some of the people who are trying
to avoid coming before your committee
are trying to run out the clock knowing
that if republicans take the house in
november and are sworn in in january
this committee is is essentially over is
your plan to be done
long before that in order to prevent an
interruption before you're done with
your work as a result of the election
[Music]
to have our hearings begin
tonight uh there will be six hearings uh
at least that take place in the month of
june um there will be um
uh
perhaps another hearing or two in the
future to deliver the recommendations of
the committee and there will be a report
and we're hoping to have all of that
done
um early in the fall
uh you know it's not just our committee
that ends with this congress everything
ends with this congress because
house of representatives
uh unlike the senate
is a new
newly constituted body every two years
you know we come to the end of the
congress and then there's a new congress
that forms the senate because of the
overlapping nature of their terms is a
continuing body they only lose one-third
of their members
or one-third of their members are up for
re-election whereas our entire body's up
for re-election and we adopt new rules
at the beginning of the house and so on
so it's not any kind of strategic
political calculus it's just that we've
got to get this done before uh this
session of congress ends okay when it
comes to gun safety there have been some
of your colleagues who have said
something feels different this time
we've seen a couple of republicans
including adam kinzinger and
congressman jacobs who have said i
actually have a new position when it
comes to either an assault weapons ban
or ar-15 i'm
there's something that that might be a
little bit different this time but we've
seen this cycle for a long time which is
there's a mass shooting everybody says
we must do something republicans come in
and say oh yeah sure but that can
include actually dealing with gun safety
and then there's no major shooting in
the news for a couple of weeks and
nothing happens and it's rinse repeat
for year after year after year is your
genuine opinion that this is going to be
that same cycle or that maybe something
will be different this time
well
you know my colleagues senior to me
believe it is going to be the exact same
thing it's been before because the nra
exerts such a stranglehold over
the gop and
in the final analysis as they will
refuse to move uh on the other hand um
yeah i'm of the mind that
the republicans think that they are in
a place where they can actually
seize control of the house and the
senate and they can
win these elections um you know they've
obviously been
vilifying and demonizing joe biden
and
yet they're starting to realize that the
public is overwhelmingly against them on
all the big issues i mean you know they
are the dog that caught the car
when it comes to destroying road versus
wade in the constitutional right to
privacy so that creates uh explosive
political conditions where the women of
america can turn on mass against the gop
and what they've done to destroy women's
reproductive freedom
similarly
uh the
the gun violence is so out of control
and so
dangerous and frightening to people
that there could they could experience a
similar
[Music]
earthquake with young people in america
who just say enough is enough and
uh the young people uh who
really rocked american politics from
parkland florida
uh with the march for our lives um are
organizing another march
um and people are saying that hundreds
of thousands or maybe even a million
people could come to washington um so i
think that the gop may have the sense
that uh their big chance to do what they
really care about most which is taking
power um could all be squandered
because of the recklessness of their
policies and so that would argue that
they might try to do something
so that they're not so clearly the party
that is tagged with all these massacres
one of my constituents wrote me the
other day with the idea that the
massacres
should be named after the republican
members of congress and the senators
whose districts and states they
represent when those are the members who
are doing nothing to
get us a universal violent criminal
background check doing nothing to
close the
you know the gun show loophole the
internet loophole the private seal
loophole doing nothing
uh to take weapons of war out of the
hands of 18 year olds and
um
you know essentially reduce the
slaughter which puts america into a
class completely of its own i mean you
know we're suffering uh gun casualties
20 times 25 50 times higher um than
other
industrialized countries and it's all
because
you know on that note um
many of my liberal friends
who are for
all sorts of different gun safety
regulations which i know you support and
which i support
also are of the mindset that they don't
love the idea of only the right wingers
having the guns and they are
increasingly seeking firearms themselves
and obtaining them almost like a race to
the bottom of sorts if you will do
do you sympathize with that fear does
that does that make sense to you to some
degree
well
i mean the supreme court of course in
heller versus district of columbia said
that the core of
the individual right under the second
amendment is the right of self-defense
in your home and
people have that right that's deeply
anchored in american culture and law
and um
so uh if there are people who
uh are fearful
for that reason and they they feel that
firearms will keep them safe uh they you
know they have
a right to exercise their second
amendment rights um in that way of
course the liberals in the supreme court
had advanced the traditional view which
is that uh
the the second amendment is about the
right to possess guns in connection with
militia service in other words you read
the preferatory clause or well-regulated
militia being necessary the survival of
the free state
um comma
in conjunction with the operative clause
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be in french in any of it
the the conservative majority won on
that but even justice scalia uh was
emphatic
that
reasonable gun regulation is totally
within the contemplation of the second
amendment and you don't have to sell
assault weapons to
uh
anybody and you don't have to allow kids
to get weapons and you don't have to
allow people to take weapons into public
places um you know i i hope we have not
arrived at civil war style conditions
um but i you know i i think it's
perfectly healthy for people across the
political spectrum to exercise their
second amendment rights but it's also
perfectly healthy for us to understand
what second my second amendment rights
really are right and what the authority
of government is to guarantee public
safety because that's essential to the
social contract the whole reason we get
into a social contract if you read locke
and hobbs and rousseau is that we
surrender the rights of violent
self-help um in exchange for
security in a civil society uh but the
republicans who refuse to do nothing
essentially you know give us the worst
of both worlds they compel kids to go to
school under the truancy laws under the
mandatory attendance laws but then they
leave them as sitting ducks because they
won't do anything to
keep them safe from mass slaughter with
assault weapons
congressman last thing i want to ask you
about and i know our time is is not
unlimited i'm not an advocate of a
primary challenge to joe biden i think
if joe biden decides to run for
reelection that he should be the
democratic nominee from a strategic
point of view that being said when
people say to me
david is there anyone you think would be
interesting to see as the democratic
nominee to be totally honest i think of
you i think of john ossoff i think john
offset would be very interesting i know
that it would be
a crazy thing to ask you if it's
something you think about thinking about
you would never answer it it would be
inappropriate it would be a crazy thing
to ask but my more specific question is
one of the things i do think is i think
that
unfortunately because of anti-semitism
on both the right and some on the left
i think jewish presidential candidates
would still struggle because of
anti-semitism what's your opinion about
that issue in america right now
i hadn't really thought that through
david uh well let me see um and i i
wonder if you're asking me this because
i i happen to be in new hampshire
campaigning for my friends uh chris
pappas and annie kuster and for senator
maggie hassan uh but
um
you know look
i think it's really important for the
young people of america to understand
and the kids of america to understand
despite what they might see on the
internet and despite what they might
hear from some people in public office
we are not a racist country we are not
an anti-semitic country we are not a
sexist misogynistic country we are not
an immigrant bashing country and
um i believe uh so much in you know what
tom payne saw when he got to america i
mean he said this country
could become an asylum for humanity not
an insane asylum mind you but it could
become a place of refuge for people
fleeing from every form of political
religious economic repression and
discrimination on earth
and i think despite what we've lived
with through donald trump and the proud
boys and the oath keepers and the
militia groups and the three percenters
and despite all of the divisiveness and
the polarization i still believe we are
the world's greatest multi-racial
multi-religious multi-ethnic
constitutional democracy and the sky's
the limit for what we can make happen
for our people once we fight off all of
these authoritarian racist attacks
on our country so
um
you know there there would be a lot of
reasons that i wouldn't run for
president but being jewish would not be
one of them
congressman jamie raskin i really
appreciate your time and we're going to
be watching next week as the hearings
start very closely thank you so much
thanks so much for having me david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show our friends from the good liars
have done it again uh davrum and jason
from the good liars were at the nra
conference over the weekend they asked a
guy in a confederate flag shirt is he
for slavery or is he against slavery and
the guy didn't want to comment now in my
world if you don't say i'm against
slavery you might be in favor of it but
i'll let you guys be the judge of that
these are extremely good videos that the
guys have been doing this is jason
interviewing this guy
um guys wearing a black make america
great again hat and a keep flying
confederate flag shirt the topic is well
that connects to slavery are you for or
against slavery and the guy pleads the
fifth on the easiest question in the
world take a look at this just keep it
flying
keep it fly
and why do you want to keep it flying
why do you want to why would anybody
want to erase our heritage
well some people would say that that
flag symbolizes uh racism it symbolizes
slavery
um and they might have some valid points
there
that's their opinion you know they
welcome their opinion if they want it
are you are you pro-slavery you're
against slavery
i have no comment
[Laughter]
no comment guys he is not going to weigh
in on that uh controversial
venomous political issue
thank you for the interview
i'll give you one more chance
pro bro or anti-slavery
no comment
[Music]
i what i'll give you does he know you
can be against slavery and still like
guns i mean
i don't know it's it's a very um
it's i would not want to leave any doubt
my position on slavery one more
opportunity to say if you're pro or
anti-slavery no
no comment
all right well there you have it no no
comment on the uh if you're in favor of
slavery or not
it's it is uh you know
it's a real gotcha question are you for
or against slavery now
let's be very
honest with ourselves and each other
we shouldn't be shocked
that some of the people with the
confederate flag gear
are pro-slavery that's what the
confederacy was fighting to preserve at
the end of the day you know i i know
that it's
it's so common it's almost cliche that
when you say to someone who loves the
confederate flag paraphernalia you say
this stands for slavery this stands for
racism and so on they go no no no no i'm
against all those things for me it
stands for
heritage or you know whatever the case
may be and maybe for some of them that's
plausibly true
but at a certain point
the people that are still using the
confederate paraphernalia
some of them are going to be for slavery
and it seems like uh the guys that the
good liars may have found
such such a guy
um
really disturbing stuff and again we've
talked about this overlap you know the
nra claims to be a non-partisan
organization they're just about gun
rights it's overwhelmingly republicans
it's overwhelmingly wrapped up with
christianity it's overwhelmingly
wrapped up with conspiratorial trumpism
and we saw literally the christian
pastor that trump brought up on the
stage during his nra speech who said i
believe you're still the president
you're still my president
uh
extremist right-wing christian pastor
nra member so we've got to admit and
understand that that overlap uh exists
and how we deal with it i don't know
there's some interesting news which is
uh it's good news but it's also not
nearly enough new york is going to be
raising the age to buy an assault rifle
from 18 to 21 and new york is going to
be banning body armor
widely reported including by bloomberg
governor kathy hoechel and legislative
leaders pledged to raise the legal age
to purchase an ar-15 assault rifle in
new york to 21 from 18
and pass a package of measures to
tighten gun laws before the end of the
state's legislative session this week
citing the mass shootings in buffalo new
york and uvalde texas local officials
say they want to close loopholes and
address the gaps in laws exposed by the
back-to-back massacres the bills would
prohibit the purchase of body armor for
civilians require a license to purchase
a semi-automatic rifle
make threatening mass harm a crime and
strengthen the state's red flag laws the
measures would also require new pistols
to have micro stamping technology which
uses lasers to implant mark imprint
markings to make it easier to trace guns
to registered
owners
illinois washington hawaii and florida
have already raised the age from 18 to
21 for assault rifles so this is great
right but
neighboring pennsylvania you still only
have to be 18 to buy an assault rifle in
neighboring new jersey you still have to
be only 18 to buy an assault rifle and
in new jersey adults can buy and use
bulletproof vests and body armor unless
you have a felony conviction and in
pennsylvania there are no extra body
armor regulations besides federal laws
so in pennsylvania adults can still buy
and use bulletproof vests and you could
say well but david it would be against
the law to cross state lines or right
yeah but it's still extraordinarily easy
to do and so you get the idea we need
some kind of broader
probably federal legislation on a lot of
this stuff now
one of the things we have to remember
is if the crime is going to be where
there's more population and work we've
got a piece planned on this issue of
um
the the gun violence is in so-called
democrat cities you all know as i've
explained before
cities in general lean democratic and
high crime cities and low crime cities
are
basically run by democrats democrats
just live in cities and crime is more
prevalent where there is more population
density so
we might understand well the population
centers are where you're going to see
more crime but if it's that easy for
people to go to jersey and pennsylvania
for the weapons or to go from chicago
into indiana
this type of thing might actually
backfire statistically in what shows up
good for new york city good for the
state of new york but we really need a
national effort here now in terms of 18
versus 21 i would actually go to 25 on
uh semi-automatic assault weapons now
you might say but david why not ban them
all together sure i'm trying to be
realistic to some degree
and when you look at the ages of many of
these mass shooters
you have a situation where you've
overwhelmingly got shooters under 25
using a semi-automatic assault rifles so
you could deal with a ton of the mass
shootings specifically by targeting
those firearms in those individuals now
of course we should be doing much more
and as i've said before what you do to
deal with gun suicides versus individual
gun homicides versus mass shootings
three different problems three different
sets of solutions we talked about this
tuesday on the bonus show with pat
but this is at least one thing that can
be done and uh you know unfortunately in
my interview in the last segment
congressman jamie raskin was not super
optimistic that this time it's going to
go differently in terms of getting
republicans on board to actually do
something but
even though it's not enough even though
it doesn't go far enough even though
it's not happening in enough places to
make a difference yet
new york is at least doing something
listen canada is doing more as a result
of mass shootings in the united states
than the united states is doing and
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p you know yesterday i
played a voicemail where someone
corrected my pronunciation of the city
in texas where the recent mass shooting
took place and i explained you know the
problem is
for me i see as a native spanish speaker
i see it and for me it's
and so i don't know if it's uvalde or
yuval day these are all incorrect
anglicized pronunciations for me it's
but i don't tend to use those
pronunciations because people get all
worked up about it
the voicemail i received about it case
in point refers to my spanish
pronunciations as exaggerated that's my
whole point they're not exaggerated
they're just the pronunciations listen
to this
david i just wanted to say
i love it when you do your sort of
exaggerated spanish pronunciation
this is exactly he says he loves it but
he's still calling them exaggerated i i
don't find it offensive i just find it
funny that
just the real pronunciations
attract so much attention and are called
exaggerated they're just the
pronunciations it's sort of like if i
say apple
wow
what an exaggerated american
pronunciation of that no it's just how
you say apple in english it's like if
i'm speaking in spanish
and i refer to the former president of
the uh
united states
uh i say donald trump it's not an
exaggerated english pronunciation it's
just the pronunciation of names and
where it's it's i find it very uh
refreshing and uh
i find it delightful to listen to
good i don't know how to say you valde
in fact whenever i hear the word my
brain immediately goes to vivaldi the uh
yes of course the composer of the four
seasons and many other great pieces
italian baroque composer who wrote the
four seasons and there's things maybe on
the bonus show and you have time maybe
you can like i know you talk about
baseball sometimes maybe you can uh read
the starting lineups of your favorite
team or something and pronounce all the
names for us that would be a lot of fun
thanks david
i love the show and yeah
we'll turn it into a uh we'll we'll turn
it
into a sideshow jd martinez
that'll be a special uh that if we get
to our 1.5 million subscribers i'll just
read read spanish names all right okay
anyway it's not a big deal but it is
funny
on the bonus show today by the way we
will talk about following the uvalde
school shooting
canada
is proposing new gun safety regulations
canada is doing more as a result of the
school shooting in the u.s
than the u.s is doing at least for now
we are going to talk about
one of the victims that was shot in the
brooklyn subway mass shooting another
recent mass shooting
she is suing the gun maker glock for
damages and we're going to talk about
um the impact of such a lawsuit
and we have not spoken about this on the
show or the bonus show at all
but it is finally over other than all of
the appeals that are coming the johnny
depp amber heard case is finally over it
has captivated much of the country
although i don't know that my audience
has been that interested in it for uh
weeks if not months
johnny depp mostly won his defamation
case against amber heard my interest in
it now
are the extrapolations that are being
made about the metoo movement about male
victims of domestic violence and so many
different things so we will finally
address it now that it's over mostly on
the bonus show
sign up for the bonus show at
joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code big voting22
but remember alex jones hates the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad right
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pagman well many people do okay
thank you alex you can sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code big voting22
all of those stories and more
today
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below